hey guys also going to theater this is
Jenna and today we are celebrating the
fourth of July got so festive I saw
these decorations at Target I just
wanted to make sure I pointed them out
you know what it looks like it looks
like when you crack an egg put it on
stove and then you like cut around the
egg and then there's the white it's like
you just put that went I think I should
have chosen some other decoration today
we are making two different types of
cupcakes we are making some red white
and blue cupcakes and some surprise cake
have you ever seen what is a surprise
where you make cupcakes and we put stuff
in them and then it's like surprise well
if you of course instead of wall listen
I don't know you didn't tell me anything
you just an hey pour on our red shirt
that looks like okay America Trump's
well we're just living in it that's what
I say about you all right so what do we
do now I'm a double tops opponent like
there yeah here yeah I hear you like
here can't keep it ready yes if I don't
look at it nothing bad can happen ha
okay let's crack these maybe four egg
whites so what we're doing is we're
making a simple cake recipes or tada
don't put them there you one here so
what we're doing here is you're making
it simple cake recipe do cool white cake
recipe so you know how many times I've
done this enough to know why do I let
her do the egg white I don't know why
you actually did me that job because
every single time I messed up
[Music]
ready
hahaha madre school
can fill this up no I love having a big
shift so while you're doing that I'm
going to be making some of these
cupcakes filling them Haskel this
cupcake dispenser thing is probably the
coolest thing ever I bought it too long
ago and I never ended up using these
ones are half full these are going to be
our surprise cupcakes so those are going
to have comprises inside a surprise red
nope
so for the one I'm just going to fill
the bottom just a very nice work kind of
work you know you're going to spoon some
of that into this and then I'm just
airing my way although that's not
supposed to happen
so this looks very full we want to make
it like half Bowl don't worry let's go
got blue over here
okay yeah all right sure see what I'm
doing I do now I'm just going to kind of
go like this and be like a little swirl
yeah uh not too much tomorrow just like
a nice little like swirl mm-hmm haze
like freedom
yeah that's eat the chunky uh that's our
current political climate
all right now we're your breezes oven to
350 which I should have done probably
forever and ago where is this surprise
surprise no I got a baby's first oh I'm
never gonna happen
that's let's clean up and prepare our
icing okay here's our decorations we've
got our cupcake look at them nicely
placed I let them all cool off nicely so
these are America cake mm-hmm I hope you
anything surprised were they surprised
so what you're going to do with this is
you're gonna dig out the center and then
we're gonna put a surprise in the middle
yeah just cut out that middle laineebee
I just agree with what you're doing I
think it's wonderful
Oh slightly a finger welcome to America
kids we're testing our healthcare is it
to clean my poll is it good ghost our
whole breakup cycle through your arms oh
my love is icing everywhere
[Music]
portable my phone we're gonna do ah okay
so one of those wait um
so sorry I don't know how to do anything
we're cooking with people who know what
they're doing this is like basically
cute colors cuz it's not mixed well how
so fluffy
oh it's a rather is a pink I don't think
I would associate it with this video
this is oh I didn't get doesn't matter
the big brand finale of a vertical
subscribe little holiday crafts loving
the tricolor scheme
hi there's not even a single freaking
piece of red no red herb feel just
already
oh my god I'm gonna have my white man oh
that looks nice else like suicide oh
that was stupid it doesn't wrinkle
enough be writer not everyone okay but
spin it one it money's like a lobster
when it goes from blue to red yeah cool
alright guys now it's time for these
super special surprise these are a lot
of icing on here well the bat oh good I
woke up my skin prize surprise
hmm Wow I've seen better marking worse
yeah that's not right no I've only seen
better it's all gone
hope you can Isis one of like super
basics that was boring
all right oh oh well I not will let the
end of that cool I'm gonna make it real
good for you
Oh everybody hold on
what can we got what else do we have in
here we'll fill this up with some red
balls I forgot that this was for America
Oh quick all right now we need a icing
it's not burning Oh everything is
definitely burning May he didn't like it
he says he he said he doesn't care cuz I
have on do you have a one with the white
and you said surprise was way more
entertaining than like spooky but I
wanted it to be a suppose we're almost
done with this what happened here ah
thanks dude everything oh gosh why are
there tears on ya the terms of the
problem I think it was oh that's my
buddy Matt she will keep touching my
body while I sing on no room my buck
sorry well if it's not on it is going to
be on assuming so all right well I think
that we did an excellent job let's get
to a nice slow-mo look of our beautiful
works of art
[Music]
every word every copy I could have
another chance to be
[Music]
[Applause]
again close three tell me if I could
have another chance
[Music]
I'm so sick of eating cupcakes I like to
surprise I said that three hours ago
then I didn't know if the surprise was
hmm try okay thanks for watching huge
thank you to data for all throughout
this video
happy 4th of July I'll see you later I
shut my eyes trying not to be pretend am
I still your brain instantly but I still
hear you screaming
[Music]